oh hello you scared the piss up hello
that this video is a very special one
because it marks the exact one-year
anniversary that we uploaded our first
video here on slow mo guys channel 1 oh
yeah we've done quite a lot videos
really yeah wasted quite a good time I
think yeah we have waste a lot of time
sorry about that
although technically we've only wasted
this much time
now face
[Music]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
and they have it that was every episode
of the slow mo guys so far in real time
we didn't waste too much time in yeah
did hardly took any time at all in fact
so let us know what you want to see in
year 2 of the slow mo guys like you
wanna see more behind the scenes stuff
alongside our regular stuff
yeah buddy done much that no you haven't
they what about some outtakes we got
quite a lot of these yeah every about
takes yeah we can whip up some at 8:00
yeah yeah well thanks to everybody
subscribed refresh you have got over
300,000 of you brilliant and hopefully
you'll continue to watch us in you two
closing words
don't have any place in woods Oh
you say some really profound - found
[Music]